this is a message to everybody who is
deemed in not a Central Business during
covid the good news the recession will
not be as bad as a hundred percent of
your business not being able to be open
the covid period shifted money around
there are people who got super super
rich because all of the dollars that
used to go to gyms used to go to
restaurants got shifted towards other
ones that were deemed essential virtual
all these things that boomed I think the
equal opposite may happen so if you had
your Heyday during covet and everything
was amazing you may not be nearly as
prepared as the people who went through
the hardship of 10 12 18 months where
they literally were not allowed to do
business and made do you know what it
looks like to work double time and
you're just gonna have to buckle up for
understanding that to have the same
amount of sales that you were right now
or a few months ago you're just going to
have to work twice as hard and that's
okay and everyone else who doesn't
you'll be able to glob up all that
market share in the meantime